Messer abwehren Schläge abblocken
wendeten verordnungsdienst der Stadt
Aachen trainiert regelmäßig bei
Ausbilder Volker Haupt es geht rauer zu
auf den Straßen beide haben schon
erschreckende Erfahrungen gemacht von
kapselandrissen über eine bisunde
angespuckt von der infektiösen Person
Beleidigung und natürlich die Social
Media Sache sind ja die ganze Breite ist
dabei ich habe einmal einen Kollegen
erlebt der selber Nothilfe leisten
musste während einer Kollegin ja fast
erwürgt worden ist und ähm ich kann
Ihnen sagen wenn sie solche Menschen
erleben in der Nachsorge da fließend
erst vor einigen Tagen Fahrzeugkontrolle
an diesem Kölner Flüchtlingsheim mehrere
Bewohner attackieren die Beamten ein
Polizist der leidet ein Jochbeinbruch
mehr als die Hälfte der Mitarbeiter des
öffentlichen Dienstes haben Gewalt oder
Beleidigungen erlebt so die Studie des
Beamtenbundes bei Polizistinnen und
Polizisten sind es 64% bei
Feuerwehrleuten die Leben retten noch
41% bei Lehrerinnen und Lehrern 37
was tun die bundesinnenministerin
reagiert heute ausreichend will mehr
Strafanzeigen
dafür brauche ich aber Vorgesetzte die
das mit unterstützen weil diese Grenze
darf nicht verschoben werden die
Menschen dürfen nicht merken wenn sie
sich übel verhandelten gegenüber Beamten
dass es einfach so durchgeht sondern das
muss auch Konsequenzen haben doch gibt
es die ein Feuerlöscher fliegt in der
Silvesternacht auf die Windschutzscheibe
eines Rettungswagens gezielt geworfen
gerade bei solchen Massen Delikten
ermittelt die Polizei nur selten
einzelne Täter und selbst Rettungskräfte
erleben regelmäßig Angriffe
da kann ich schnell mal passieren dass
eine Flasche fliegt das gehört was zum
Alltag dazu das kommt vor dass natürlich
beschimpft wird das auch mal gegen das
Fahrzeug quasi getreten gehämmert wird
während der Behandlung des Türen
aufgerissen werden die Kommunen rüsten
derweil auf auch die Amtsräume im
Aachener Sozialamt zeigt Sachbearbeiter
Thorsten Kretsch die
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen Regel Nummer 1
Zutritt nur mit Termin
was sind die nachgerüsteten Türen also
hier mit Türspion das heißt wir sehen
von innen wer draußen vor der Tür steht
was sehr wichtig ist und wir haben die
Panik geschlossen das heißt von außen
kann keiner rein es ist abgeschlossen
und wir können jederzeit wieder raus
auch die Nachbar Büros sind schon als
Fluchtweg eingeplant für den Ernstfall
gibt es einen notfall-code der Kollegen
alarmiert es gab schon eine Geiselnahme
und ein Übergriff auf eine Kollegin
also einmal PC runter geworfen
Schreibtisch also umgeschmissen
Schranktüren aufgerissen und die
Kollegen ist halt auch ja hat das Büro
verlassen musste fliehen
Ordnungskräfte üben Nahkampf Bürgerbüros
brauchen Alarmanlagen Beamte sind
Repräsentanten des Staates immer mehr
Menschen reagieren an ihnen ihren Frust
ab